2016 is a very exciting year for Robbie
Amell and Italia Ricci he's back on the
flash and she's on Supergirl
but more importantly they're getting
married how's the wedding planning going
because she's not allowed to talk about
it I got trouble for ELISA the date once
you did I did just find out that she
tried on her wedding dress as a joke and
decided to go with that one so I have
that to look forward to yeah the dress
is picked out as is a flower girl Italia
tells ET exclusively that honor goes to
ma vie amel daughter of Robbie's cousin
Aerostar Stephen Amell the couple has
plenty to celebrate Italia has been cast
as BADgal silver banshee and Supergirl
and Robbie will return to the flash but
as the villainous death storm it's very
very cool it might be more fun to be bad
until then fans can catch Robbie as
agent Miller in the x-files revival
coming to Fox January 24th my first
scene was with David and Gillian and it
was one of those weird moments where
you're you're living a small part of TV
history and I'll never forget it